Qatar welcoming the world
long before the fans arrived came the
MPS dozens visited the country before
the World Cup and Sky News is
Westminster accounts project can reveal
the Qatari government spent over 240
000 pounds in hosting them MPS insist
their visits were purely educational but
this part of a system that some say is
all about persuasion
all party parliamentary groups where MPS
from all sides can come together around
shared interests and issues they do
research make visits and publish reports
Loosely regulated they have no official
status in Parliament but they're a big
part of the Westminster system and what
they say carries weight MPS are calling
for a review of the use of so-called
smart motorways he now says he'll be
starting a new group of MPS to push that
further saw types are drugs laws British
parliamentarians are worried the Saudi
package won't meet UK travel regulations
MPS want the manufacturer to make amends
if they get us pressure being exerted on
companies who frankly have got away with
murder
huge influence in the public debate but
what happened behind closed doors
whether you're lobbying for a bank a
religion or a nation-state
appgs might not be well known but they
are big business
20 million pounds has been funneled into
them over the course of this Parliament
alone most of that goes on paying for
organizers reports research events and
trips and there are plenty of these
appgs to put money into
753 active groups that's more of them
than there are sitting members of
parliament
and these are the ones that are getting
the most money so many different
subjects covered here in just the top
five banking Christianity leveling up
Tech and artificial intelligence there's
an appg for every sector and every cause
and this is where the money is coming
from names you've probably never heard
of but what they say they do is
revealing of the top 10 six of these
companies are registered for lobbying
and many others have a clear agenda
so much of life in Westminster is
lobbying the art of persuasion Central
to politics and appgs can provide a rich
canvas it takes just five MPS to set one
up and companies can fund them directly
giving to a group that matches their
cause or they can give cash via a
lobbying group
it's their job to convince politicians
and governments to do what they want but
it's not always easy to get them to
speak on camera so when I was offered
the chance to share an event on lobbying
in Parliament I couldn't possibly say no
and we've got a brilliant panel here
tonight to talk through that a room of
lobbyists making the case that they can
be a force for good they see appgs as a
powerful tool I know our appg helps
influence
getting more money for Northern culture
and the leveling up like people living
up from we did that we know that with
Net Zero we know the action fans uh the
2030 Target was reduced because of what
we said we think that but it was had
influence and that's bringing that group
together it's really effective but
finding it hard to defend the system
some people worry that apbgs are used
through the secretariats and thought
that you run in order to push particular
corporate agendas
is that true
I think it might be true I think
probably
most groups do things or operate the way
we do I think there are minority of
appgs that are funded by certain
organizations who are peddling their
line
and they are trying to unfairly
influence parliamentary decisions there
are too many of them and it's too easy
to set them up where there's a potential
problem is in the lack of transparency
on funding lack of transparency on their
objectives and the lack of transparency
on how they behave within Parliament can
you name some examples or give some
scenarios where there's an issue
why not uh no because there are 650 to
choose from so but you think they're an
issues that you know that there are
issues with some of them because they're
not doing what they say on the team
they're actually tools of individual
corporate vested interests and there's
no way of stopping it don't say that do
you think there's unethical Behavior
with appgs at the moment
it's not a no I know
Stark warning from one of the
government's top ethics Watchdogs season
this is the next uh big Scandal unless
we take action well a number of them are
um the Secretariat comes from
professional organizations from uh from
lobbying groups and from
organizations are a bit of glass to
grind
and I don't think there is sufficient
transparency in terms of um why they're
doing it there are clear examples of a
business putting its money into an appg
to try and influence policy the CBD appg
are funded by a single company with a
specific interest tenacious labs open
that easing cannabis regulations is the
company's goal but they say it's the MPS
who call the shots
what you have to do is you have to
persuade some MPS or officers of you
know officers there five of them that
it's of sufficient interest to them
um that if you do a bunch of grunt work
to supply them with the heavy lifting
that they're prepared to spend some time
on it and it's there appg not ours and
they make that very clear as we go along
providing them with sensible first
drafts for a discussion to happen around
and that's that's our job we work for
the appg we we don't you know we're not
the tail wagging the dog
[Music]
millions of pounds going into a largely
unregulated part of the political system
many all party groups work to inform and
educate but even those who work at the
heart of them admit they could be open
to abuse the Westminster accounts makes
it easier to follow the money